nous parlons aux politiques à présent
c'est notre actualité de ce début de
semaine la demande officielle de rohr
berger à l'ump afin d'obtenir
l'investiture pour les prochaines
municipales à magny les hameaux la
conseillère politique de 26 ans se veut
particulièrement actif ces derniers mois
sur la commune lors du dernier rendez
vous citoyen qu'elle a organisé il ya
quelques semaines à l'ancien ministre
chantal jouanno a d'ailleurs répondu
présentes dans soir hors berger enfin
merci d'être en ligne avec vous c'est
avec nous cette demande d'investiture
pour vous est ce que c'est le bon timing
c'est vous suivez un petit peu le
calendrier vous vous étiez fixés je suis
qu'a fait le calendrier que je m'étais
fixé ça fait plusieurs années maintenant
que je suis impliqué magny les hameaux
l'élection municipale a lieu dans moins
d'un an donc je confesse le naturel de
folie que d'abord lors de futures de mon
parti une fois que j'aurai fait pareil
figure en tout cas j'espère l'obtenir la
campagne sera longue et fine plume à
l'encré
vous vous êtes engagé à 16 ans a
lui-même payé à une dizaine d'années
vous avez été responsable des jeunes
populaires des yvelines avant d'entrer
au bureau national chargé de mission
également ce sera vraiment votre
première campagne pour vous présenter
vous même puisque vous avez soutenu
plusieurs campagnes que ce soit celle de
la de valérie pécresse encore françois
fillon dans les campagnes internes
vous avez le sentiment d'être légitime
pour vous présenter à une élection
municipale d'avoir levé ti suffisant je
pense que je suis mieux pew regard du
travail de terrain que je fais à lundi
il ya deux sont liés à la fois mon
engagement au sein de l'ump
en effet depuis un certain nombre
d'années même si je suis jeune nokia
surtout l'engagement que j'ai au
quotidien à la nuit à la fois un
engagement associatif un engagement avec
le collectif même une nouvelle énergie
on est là pour à la fois réaliser
quelles sont les difficultés
quotidiennes de la micro et surtout
temple et d'y apporter des véritables
solutions et laborie un projet de
reconquête pour février et que nous
présenterons progressivement même y
croire dans un cégep a actuellement
conseil municipal vous n'étiez pas
candidate aux dernières élections
municipales comment ont réagi les
élections les élus actuels de
l'opposition ump et on travaille main
dans la main en fait depuis mon arrivée
sur la commune depuis quelques années
elle n'était pas là en effet en 2008
nous travaillons main dans la main et
certains membres des vues aujourd'hui
dans l'opposition seront et sont allés
côté déjà pour la reconquête de manille
vous demander l'investiture et
finalement ce sera pas véritablement une
surprise vous devriez la voir vous êtes
plutôt proche de valérie pécresse
valérie pécresse qui est la chef de file
dans le département de l'ump lassé
poursuivre justement les procédures que
vous demandez cette investiture il ya
une procédure en effet un calendrier qui
a été arrêté et moi je vais me conforme
je pense qu'il faut être se conformer
aux règles qui ont été fixées
la règle c'est que ça craint policier
pierre le futur de son parti je le fais
donc je ne pense pas qu'il y ait
d'autres candidatures ump sur la commune
je pense qu'on a réussi justement à
créer et livrer une vraie cohésion
d'équipé qui fait aujourd'hui 4 il
devrait être la seule à feu vif et
l'investiture et que donc je devrais
l'obtenir ils ont leurs fans par effet
naturel de d'abord de non violent des
figures de mon parti le verdict sera
pour quand la décision de l'ump
le calendrier est à vous de le rappeler
dans l'écriture normalement sur le
département
donc on attend encore le calendrier
précis ville par ville mais avant les
clés de toute façon on fera qu il fera
avec lui sur les communes et donc y
compris à même les hamon merci roberge
et probable candidate donc à magny les
hameaux aux élections municipales en
tout cas de candidate à l'investiture ne
manque plus que la décision de l'ump sur
cette demande merci à vous et puis pour
ceux qui veulent suivre ce scrutin
municipal la campagne également qui
débute rendez vous dès ce samedi sur
notre antenne pour une nouvelle édition
et du nouveau rendez-vous du magazine
politique de la rédaction municipales
2014 le scrutin je vous le rappelle se
déroule en mars